- Ah, crap!
- [Narrator] This is what
that scene looked like
behind the scenes.
(upbeat music)
And that's not a stunt double.
Tom Holland got hit by
this car replica 17 times,
then had to lunge himself forward
to remain horizontal for
the rest of the stunt.
And it's not the first time
Tom has done his own stunts.
As a trained acrobat and gymnast,
he's dropped hundreds of feet in the air
and has backflipped off a replica
of the Washington Monument.
Here are five dangerous
stunts Tom performed himself.
(Tom grunts)
- So fun.
- [Narrator] For 2019's
"Spider-Man: Far from Home,"
Tom trained with stunt
coordinator George Cottle
for five weeks to prepare
for all of the film's stunts.
But the most intense was
this web-swinging sequence
with MJ, played by Zendaya.
Spider-Man's iconic skyscraper swings
have been a consistent
challenge in the franchise,
predominately created using
CGI in the earlier films.
But for Tom, the filmmakers leaned
into practical stunts as much as possible.
Tom had a bodycam attached to him,
and both actors were raised by a crane
with a wire rig to over 100 feet.
The two were then dropped
and swung in an arc,
with cardboard boxes placed below them
as a safety precaution.
To capture the landing and takeoff,
they were lifted BTS by
cranes to different heights
outside of Grand Central Station
and Madison Square Garden.
And for close-up shots of them in midair,
a large blue screen and
wind fans were set up
in the parking lot of a Brooklyn school,
the interior of which was used
for Peter Parker's high school.
According to Zendaya, the
shot from 100-foot-high swing
wasn't included in the final cut,
but the final shot combined
in-camera practical stunts
with digidoubles for seamless movements
like never before in the series.
You might think the
Washington Monument scene
in 2017's Spider-Man:
Homecoming was all CGI,
but that was really Tom
climbing and leaping around
to save his friends.
Various sections of the
monument were replicated
and built on a soundstage in Atlanta.
Specifically, the side
of the monument was built
at an angle for the initial ascent.
Then wires assisted Tom
in the practical climb.
With clever camera angles,
the filmmakers created the illusion
that the building was actually vertical.
Tom then had to perform various
jumps off another replica
that represented the very top
and the sides of the building.
Here he is doing a backflip
off the top into the air,
assisted with cables.
And in this shot he's doing a backflip
into what's known in the
stunt world as a face-off,
which prevents injury upon impact
by landing flat on his back.
For stunts that were impossible
or too dangerous to perform,
like swinging from the helicopter,
the filmmakers used CG.
But the movements were based
on motion-captured footage
of Tom's actual stunt work.
This made the final CG shots
appear even more realistic
and in Tom's signature style.
Later in the same Monument
scene of Homecoming,
Spider-Man is pulled headfirst
into an elevator shaft.
Tom considered this scene
one of his wildest stunts for Homecoming.
It required him to have his
legs in a split position,
and then nose dive off a
ledge, suspended with wires.
Tom was initially hesitant
about doing this himself,
according to his stunt
double Chris Silcox.
On top of his nerves, Tom
had to wear a corset harness,
which was so tight he was worried
about throwing up in his mask.
In the end, Tom decided
to attempt the stunt
without using the stunt double.
(all cheer)
"In Spider-Man: Far From Home,"
Tom wasn't dealing with just
heights, but water as well.
He needed to navigate quickly
in and out of bot the canals
and boats during this
battle with the Elementals.
The crew recreated Venice
as a soundstage near London
with exact replicas of the Rialto bridge.
They also recreated restaurants
and blue-green canal water.
To pull off this sequence safely,
Tom practiced leaping
across wider platforms
in a clip he shared on his Instagram.
For the actual stunt, he
was attached to a wire
while he ran across a
row of poles in the canal
and finally pole-vaulted onto the bridge.
Tom later said he regretted
not wearing shin guards
like the stunt coordinator suggested.
The water was practically manipulated
to create massive waves slamming into Tom
as he fought the Elementals.
At one point, he was rigged to a ratchet
and pulled backwards into
the wall of the bridge,
then soaked with thousands
of gallons of water.
He had to perform this stunt twice.
His stunt double Greg
Townley stood for a few takes
when the wave initially
struck Tom on the bridge,
which Tom poked fun at on his Instagram.
(men shout)
- Greg?
Tom described this stunt
in 2022's "Uncharted"
as the most difficult of his
career, and for good reason.
The scene required him
to jump through midair
from one set of flying cargo
containers to the next,
then get hit by a car
and ejected from a plane.
The crew built a blue screen
set in the parking lot
of the studio to help
capture natural daylight.
This scene using crates was
shot in two separate sequences.
For the first sequence, when
Tom falls out of the plane,
supervising stunt coordinator Scott Rogers
decided to stage the action vertically
to better simulate flying through the air.
The special effects team
used giant robotic arms
to safely hold and move the boxes.
And Tom was secured with wires
as he hung onto the crates
and flew through the air.
For the second sequence,
when Tom is climbing back into the plane
and jumping crate to crate,
the boxes were held more horizontally.
And for this final collision with the car,
- Ah, crap!
- [Narrator] the team
built the front section
of a fake vehicle,
which was replaced by a
CGI car in the final cut.
Tom and the fake car were
attached to the same rig,
with the actor wearing three sets of wires
to stabilize him.
The rig pulled the fake hood towards Tom,
knocking him backwards.
He then needed to remain horizontal
while flying out of the plane.
To get this shot, Tom had to
be fake hit around 17 times,
with this entire scene taking
several weeks to complete.
The result?
A realistic stunt that
matches the excitement
from the popular video game
scene it was pulled from.
(Nathan screams)
(upbeat music)